[Music]
President Trump is calling for
democratic senator Jon Tester to resign
tweeting that a lot of testers
allegations against White House dr.
Ronnie Jackson are being proven wrong
the president even brought it up at his
Michigan rally this weekend tester
started throwing out things that he's
heard well I know things about tester
that I could say to
and if I said him he'd never be elected
again Jackson dropped his name from
consideration as VA secretary nominee
late last week after allegations of
drunk driving and improper behavior on
the job but Fox News has learned the
Defense Department Inspector General has
received the allegations into Jackson is
assessing next state steps in this case
but also that the Secret Service looked
into this and a thorough review of GSA
documents and police documents provided
by the White House that there is no
evidence that Jackson wrecked his car
after drinking at a party in fact none
of the reports involve drunk driving or
anything that would fit the description
accorded the Secret Service of charges
that the Democrats leveled at Jackson
senior political analyst Brit Hume joins
us now with just what's going on here
could be any Brittain well Brett it was
also the case that he was accused in the
tester Act in the tester comments of
having drunkenly been banging on a
woman's door during a foreign trip
during the Obama administration to the
point where the Secret Service had to
had to get control of him to keep him
from waking up the president Secret
Service says that it has no record of
any such incident what clearly happened
here Brett I think is it is that tester
got a hold of a bunch of anonymous
allegations against Ronnie Jackson and
it's perfectly legitimate for a senator
to collect such things and to look into
them what he did instead was without
verifying them he didn't simply release
them to the public which I think has
been widely viewed as being below the
belt
after all Brett there were plenty of
reasons relating to Ronnie Jackson and
his lack of administrative experience as
to whether he was qualified to run a
giant bureaucracy like the VA and there
was plenty of reason to question that
and perhaps he was not the best man for
the job
but what tester did was a former
character assassination unverified
allegations haven't we had enough
experience over this past year with
unverified allegations and their use
yeah
as a political cudgel is it is it
effective he's up for re-election in
Montana a state where President Trump
won more than 80% of the counties
there's not really a strong opposition
candidate
but is it an effective tool in the
midterm election hopes of John tester to
squelch them well you know my first
instinct would be to say yeah if this
guy did this sleazy thing and the
president and the Republicans make an
issue of it out there that might hurt
him but remember this Brett the news
cycle that we're living through these
days is so rapid that by the time you
know the fall rolls around and the
campaign is on I'm not sure how many
people will remember Ronnie Jackson and
remember very much about the incident
it's just that you know we live in such
an accelerated pace in politics these
days that things that seemed like
they're just huge and gonna last forever
lasts about 36 hours and then we're on
to something else so I think it's
possible they could make an issue of it
but it's not all clear to me that
remember brother tell me get to the fall
that's right we're one tweet away from
changing the whole deal let me ask you
about this you listen to the Ambassador
Dermer from Israel and you've obviously
up on the Iran nuclear deal your
thoughts on this as the president gets
ready to make this decision by May 12th
well I think it's pretty clear that what
what Benjamin Netanyahu established
today was something that many of us in
fact most of us perhaps have expected
which was it Iran has lied repeatedly
publicly at the highest levels about its
nuclear intentions arguably that was the
reason to try to make this deal it does
that these these revelations today do
not establish the far as I can tell that
Iran has broken that deal and of course
the criticism of the deal as you heard
ambassador Dermer say is that even if it
run a run adheres to it it's such a bad
deal that we ought to get out of it of
course the counter-argument to that is
if you do if you do get out of it Iran
can accelerate its nuclear operations
and the counter to that of course is
what we can impose sanctions so we'll
see we will say Brit as always thank you
that